اداء مشرف ركله جزاء ضائعه حظ النعاسر
وتسرع امام المرمى عبارات تلخص واحده لقاء
المنتخب السعودي بنظره البولندي في سنه
جولات كاس العالم والذي خسره الاخضر
بهدفين مقابل شيء السعوديه لعبت مباراه
اخرى للذكرى الا ان التسرع ربما وغياب
التوفيق حال دون تسجيل المنتخب السعودي
لاي هدف خصوصا مع اضاعه اللاعب سالم
الدوسري لركله جزاء في الشوط الاول بعد
هدف المنتخب البولندي بدقائق وتاجل حسم
التاهل الاخضر السعودي حتى الجوله الثالثه
والاخيره من مرحله المجموعات يوم الاربعاء
المقبل
اداء يشرف بامانه يعني الاخضر السعودي كان
مسيطر بالطول العرض لكن مع الاسف الحظ لعب
دور يعني
نفس الوقت فرحان شويه زعلان على النتيجه
بس فرحان ما شاء الله السعودي الاخضر
السعودي قدم همم بالحمام ملحمه كرويه بس
الحظ مرحله في هذه المباراه وان شاء الله
مع المكسيك انا باذن الله عندي تفائل كبير
انه بيفوزوا همم وبنتهى ان شاء الله الدور
الثاني ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]